I mentioned in the last several videos
that the coefficient of kinetic friction
tends to be less sometimes it'll be
roughly equal to the coefficient of
static friction but this might lead you
to at least a question that I've had in
my mind and I still have to some degree
is why why is the coefficient of kinetic
friction lower or why can it be lower
and the current best theory that I won I
can visualize in my head and based on
the reading that I've done is the
difference between so let's think about
it this way so on a off we look at it at
a kind of a regular human level maybe we
have a block maybe we have a block so
this is the static case so let's think
about the static case over let me draw
it like this so I'll draw the static
case over here so I have a block that is
stationary on top of me to the surface
in a different color on top of some type
of surface right over here and over here
I'm going to have a block moving at some
at a constant velocity at a constant
velocity relative to some surface
relative to the same surface and so let
me draw it out so this is moving at some
constant velocity constant constant
velocity and so the interesting thing
here is assuming that these are the same
masses that these are the same surfaces
is why should the coefficient of
friction here why should the coefficient
of static friction so this is so here
since this is stationary what's under
play is the coefficient of static
friction why should that be larger than
the coefficient of kinetic friction over
here why should that be larger than the
coefficient of kinetic friction or
another way to think about it is you
would need to apply you would need to
apply more force to overcome the static
friction here and start to get this
accelerating then you would need to
apply to get this already moving body to
accelerate because there would be kind
of a less of a of a responsive friction
force so let's think about that a little
bit so what I'm going to do is zoom in
into the into the atomic level and so
when you zoom into the atomic level
almost nothing is completely smooth so
the surface
over here the surface over here might
look something like this
so I'm gonna draw it I'm gonna draw the
molecules that make up the surface so
the best to my ability so the molecules
when you zoom up really close for the
surface might look something like this
and when you so you know we're really
we're really zooming into the atomic
level unimaginably small level much
smaller than that box that is true but
I'm just trying to look at what's
happening with the atoms where they
contact are the molecules where they
contact and the boxes molecules might
look something like this the boxes
molecules might look something like this
they aren't completely smooth they
aren't completely smooth and hopefully
this video also emphasizes that all of
these forces and all this contact that
we're talking about in these videos and
it's actually interesting
philosophically nothing is ever really
in contact with each other you really
just have atoms and that are the dult
that are repulsing each other because
there are electrons they are the
electromagnetic force of repulsion
between them is not allowing them to get
any closer together so that's all when
you push something it's just the it's
just the electrons in your hand pushing
on the electron or the electron clouds
in your hand pushing on the electron
clouds of say your the pen you're
holding or the key on your keyboard or
the mug so that it so that it repulses
and causes it to go in the other
direction so that you there's no ever
there's never any this thing like real
what we imagine our heads real contact
and if you really want to blow your mind
and watch the chemistry videos if you
want to understand this is that most of
these atoms are actually free space
themselves that the electron cloud is
huge relative or I guess where most of
the probability of finding the electron
is huge compared to the size of the
electron or the size of the nucleus so
it's kind of just a lot of free space
pushing on a lot of other free space
through the electromagnetic force but
anyway we're talking about friction here
so if you were to really zoom in here
when this thing is stationary you have
the surfaces aren't actually even and so
you can imagine that these molecules
that you have sometimes when the sitting
stationary they might be kind of fit
into each other they've kind
slided slid into maybe these little ruts
here and there and so if you're trying
to move this object if you're trying to
accelerate it to the left with some
force you have to overcome essentially
either
for example this part right over here
either has to somehow break off or the
whole thing has to be shifted up a
couple of atoms or a couple of molecules
or maybe this part over here has to be
broken off or has to be shifted down one
atom you wouldn't notice these things we
wouldn't notice the shifting of a block
or the shifting of the floor you
wouldn't notice it by the the width of a
molecule or diameter of an atom or
molecule but that's essentially what
you're going to have to do or you have
to rip them off entirely in order to
start this thing moving once something
is already moving and this is at least
how I think about it a lot of it hasn't
it has it's it doesn't have a chance to
settle into these little ruts so let me
draw something that's already moving and
I'll draw the same I'll try to draw a
similar surface so I'm trying to draw
the surface that looks essentially just
like the one I drew so maybe it looks
like that this is there's supposed to be
the same surface but once it's moving
it's kind of over it can't it's not
sitting in these ruts anymore the whole
thing is moving so it's kind of sliding
across the top and so now it might look
something like this I'm trying my best
to draw it so now it might look
something like this maybe this has been
shifted up a little bit so that it can
starts lying you've overcome the you've
over overcame the static friction so now
it is so now it is let me draw the same
trying to draw the same surface here so
give or take so now it's moving it
doesn't have a chance to really settle
in it has to kind of bounce along the
top and so that's the best understanding
and so the the real the real force of
the friction here there will be still
some you know as it's moving along it
still might every now and then bounce
into little ruts here and there but you
also have you also have any type of
chemical bonds that form between the
atoms temporarily that keep breaking and
forming and in order to keep this thing
in order to keep this thing for
I guess moving or if especially if you
want to accelerate it you're going to
have to keep breaking these bonds and so
that's essentially the force of friction
that you're overcoming here you might
have those same bonds and not only do
you have those same bonds but you also
have to overcome these ruts or these
little you know these little ragged
parts that that are that have a time to
settle in to these little looks that you
have to overcome even more so that's the
intuition you know this is actually
still an area of research so it's not
like this you know cut and dry thing and
it's a fun thing to think about what's
happening at the atomic level but this
is the general intuition of why the
coefficient of static friction is higher
than the coefficient of kinetic friction